لقد قرأنا جزءًا صغيرًا من
بيان Google الذي يقول إن لديهم أعمق
التعاطف مع العائلة ولكن
اشرح لنا هنا أه لماذا لديك
أي رد فعل على هذا البيان ولكن أيضًا
لماذا تقاضي Google جميعًا وعلى
وجه التحديد لماذا
أكيد و  شكرًا لاستضافتنا، نحن
نقاضي بشكل أساسي مجموعتين من
المدعى عليهم، كان هذا طريقًا خاصًا وكنا
نقاضي المسؤولين عن
الطريق، وكان هذا تطويرًا تم
بناؤه منذ حوالي ثلاثة أو أربعة عقود،
وعندما بنوا هذا التطوير
باعوا المنازل ولكن
مسؤوليتهم لم تتوقف عند هذا الحد، بل
كانت عليهم مسؤولية إما تحويل
الطرق إلى
وزارة النقل في ولاية كارولينا الشمالية أو إنشاء
برنامج صيانة مناسب،
ولم يفعلوا ذلك أيضًا وكان هذا جسرًا
لم يرغب أحد في المجتمع في بناءه  تحمل
المسؤولية فيما يتعلق
بجوجل، كانت جوجل على علم لسنوات قبل
هذا الحادث بأن هذا الجسر قد
انهار وكان هناك في الأساس
منحدر وحفرة في وسط
حي سكني لمدة تسع سنوات،
ولا يوجد سبب وجيه لحدوث ذلك
أم و  لدينا دليل على أنه
تم تقديم العديد من الشكاوى إلى
Google من خلال تطبيق خرائط Google الخاص بهم
لإخبارهم أن هذه
مشكلة، وإخبارهم أن
هناك مقالات أظهرت أن
هذا الجسر كان خارجًا ولم يفعلوا شيئًا
أم أنا أقدر أنهم أه تعاطفوا أه
في هذا الوقت ولكن لم يكن ينبغي أبدًا
السماح بحدوث ذلك لفترة طويلة